- Today, I'm gonna show you
how a doctor goes shopping.
What you should buy in
order to stay healthy.
We're celebrating 10 million subscribers.
Huge thank you to you,
and obviously huge thank you to the team.
So we have to have a little celebration.
And with our partner, Amazon Fresh,
we're gonna go shopping
and I'm gonna show you
everything you need to know
that a doctor looks for when
they go grocery shopping.
Come on.
Huge thanks to Amazon Fresh
for sponsoring this video.
All right, I've already
broken one of my rules
in that you're not supposed to
go shopping for food hungry.
Please eat before you go food shopping.
It's so tempting to buy a
lot of unhealthy choices
just because you're hungry
in that given moment.
What's cool about this Amazon Fresh Store,
you literally scan on your app
this in-store code that I
have pulled up on my phone,
walk in, and then there's no checkout.
You just leave.
(upbeat music)
Let's start, the most
important aisle, produce.
Remember I always say plant-focused
diet is the way to go.
And look at the fresh produce.
Like I wanna go to town
on these strawberries.
For me, my breakfasts a
lot of times contain yogurt
and berries.
Why berries? Rich in vitamins.
Rich in antioxidants.
Not a lot of sugar if you
compare it to a pear, a banana.
My go-to ones, just for a
variety of taste really,
strawberries, raspberries,
and one of the most antioxidant
rich fruits out there,
blueberries.
I see a lot of people make mistakes
when it comes to mold on their berries.
If you see one berry that's
moldy, just throw that one out.
The rest are still fine.
See, what you wanna do
is get frozen berries
and vegetables that you
could use in your smoothies.
A lot of people think freezing berries
can lower the nutritional value,
but we haven't found
that to be quite true.
So load up on those frozen berries.
Blueberries, blackberries, raspberries.
And because they're frozen,
you don't even need to add ice.
See? Unagi, unagi.
I'm gonna include obviously,
along with some turkey,
some green beans.
This is a great low sodium food.
Their rich in vitamin K.
There's fiber content in here.
The type of fiber that
actually helps you lower
your LDL cholesterol.
And if you seen my other videos,
you know that I have slightly
elevated LDL cholesterol
so we're getting some green beans today.
That's absolutely a must.
Normally, I like to buy my greens loose.
When you're cooking just for yourself,
the proportions matter.
The amount you buy matters.
You don't want all of it to
spoil and just be thrown out.
But because we're preparing for a party,
I need my greens to be prepackaged.
And I really wanna focus on
spinach, kale, arugula, romaine
as the base of my salad.
Some people like using iceberg lettuce.
While that is rich in
folate and vitamin A,
I do say that the other ones tend to be
a little bit more
nutritious, have more value.
I think you could get a mixture like this
where you get baby spinach and arugula.
This has been washed, it's ready to go.
It's gonna make my life
a little bit more simple.
You can't have a salad without tomatoes.
Especially beautiful tomatoes like this.
Like this is an epitome
of a beautiful tomato.
There's some doctors out
there that claim tomatoes
are unhealthy or cause
problems with your gut.
And this is largely untrue for
the huge majority of people.
This has only two grams
of sugar in half a cup
despite it tasting sweet.
With vitamin C, potassium, folate,
like just so much nutrition.
I just wanna ah.
Speaking of Thanksgiving-esque foods,
sweet potatoes are the way
to get your complex carbs in.
You just have to be careful
if you are monitoring your caloric intake.
This could be a high calorie
food if you eat a lot of them.
You get four grams of
protein, 6.6 grams of carbs,
769% of the daily nutrition of vitamin A,
of vitamin C 65%, manganese
50%, vitamin B6 29%,
potassium 27%, copper 16%, niacin 15%.
If we're talking about nature's
multivitamin, sweet potato?
Great, great choice.
My nighttime snack, and I
know a lot of people laugh
when I did the video and I said,
"Why are you throwing out the kiwi skin?"
It's absolutely true.
If you wash them, eat it with the skin.
You're gonna be boosting the fiber intake
really significantly.
I find for myself that Kiwis
help me fall asleep better
at night.
There's some scientific proof
to this. It's a little weak.
But for me, anecdotally at
least, it's worked quite well.
And again, lots of
vitamins, lots of minerals.
(upbeat music)
Before going food shopping,
make sure to make a list
and stick to that list.
Number one tip I give to parents
is if you don't have
junk food in the house,
the kids aren't going to eat it.
And Amazon Fresh carts have
a really specific indent
to put your phone in to make sure
that you're getting all the
ingredients for your list.
When I think about sauces,
I really try and think
about the nutrients that are
gonna slide into my foods.
So for example, if I'm gonna
be eating my morning eggs
and I don't want to increase
the caloric intake of my eggs,
Tabasco sauce gives you a lot of flavor
without the calories.
Literally zero calories.
It's important to know that
depending on your condition,
you could always go for
varieties of certain foods.
Like for ketchup, they have
the no sugar added variety
if you struggle with sugar issues,
perhaps if you have diabetes.
Or the no salt added option
if you have kidney problems
or if you're struggling with
congestive heart failure.
While there are some general rules
about hyper processed
foods being unhealthy,
foods are healthy or unhealthy
depending on your current
individual life, goals,
medical conditions, and it
needs to be individualized
and tailored for you.
(upbeat music)
There's a ton of salad dressings
that are available for purchase.
I like to kind of make my own
with the most magical ingredients
and those are olive oil.
Extra virgin Greek olive oil.
and I only say magic because
of that cool transition.
There's nothing really magical about this.
It just my preference
when it comes to oils.
Balsamic vinegar.
Mixed in with the olive oil
makes perfect salad dressing.
Adds flavor. Adds kick.
(upbeat music)
If it's a sweetener and it
has carbohydrates in it,
it's basically the same thing.
So I try and go for the
manuka honey version.
We actually use medical
grade manuka honey,
not what this is.
In medicine when we're
talking about wounds
that are not responding to antibiotics,
we use manuka honey there.
So I do try and put this in my
tea if I'm not feeling great.
But also just like a
little drizzle on my yogurt
in the morning that already
has zero grams of sugar added,
I add it myself with
a little bit of honey.
And apparently there's a Mike's Hot Honey.
Great fibrous food here.
You have soluble fiber,
which does tend to keep you regular.
And the big surprise here,
six grams of protein in
just a third of a cup.
Fiber, protein? Win for me.
Now any doctor that's gonna tell you
they don't enjoy a little bit
of pie every now and then,
I feel like they're not
being honest with you.
We're celebrating. It's
okay to have some pie.
Yes, there's sugar content.
But there's great nutrients in here
because it is a berry pie.
So I try and find some kind of dessert
that always has some
added nutrition to it.
And berries, that's a great
way to boost the nutrition.
For me, because this is a
rare treat, it's occasional,
it's not gonna make or
break my healthy lifestyle.
So I'm okay having this,
especially if I have a small amount.
And I don't want you
deciding for your lifestyle
if you're eating completely
healthy or unhealthy
based on one choice.
It's about the general
philosophy that you have
when it comes to food shopping.
(upbeat music)
As I'm browsing through these aisles,
I'm really impressed with the high quality
and the amount of selection
of healthy whole foods.
Like even just walking here
and seeing this spice rack
and seeing how many options
there are, it's awesome.
For me, spices are nature's spice.
There's no better way to say it.
Because a lot of times we say,
"Oh, healthy food is boring
or doesn't taste good."
But that's because we're not using spices.
Remember, a lot of these
spices are zero or low calorie.
They are nutritious.
I even try to use spices like
cinnamon in my morning yogurt
just to add a little bit more flavor.
Or even in my coffee.
When I think about bread,
I think about maximizing
nutrition from a very simple food.
Now, this bread here has to
have the first ingredient
being whole wheat.
Not if you're gluten-free, of course.
And I want the dietary fiber
to be at least three grams.
That's telling me that
I'm in a good place.
This one's exactly three grams.
Because it has flax seeds
and other seeds on it,
you're getting a little
bit of protein as well.
Five grams of protein,
14 grams of whole grains,
and 520 milligrams of omega-3.
You're making a usually
non-nutritious food
very nutritious.
(upbeat music)
A lot of people like
to talk about vitamin D
and it's importance to health.
And I agree totally,
but a lot of people overdo it
with vitamin D supplements.
I'm trying to find foods
that have a good amount
of vitamin D content and
sardines are the way to go.
You know, some people make
fun of me for eating sardines.
But at night, if I'm hungry,
I crack open a can and have some.
Not only are you getting
a serious protein boost,
but you're getting omega-3s, vitamin D.
70% of your day's vitamin
D in just one serving.
That's three ounces of sardines.
$2.79.
If you wanna splurge a little
bit and go for the $3.29,
you're gonna get get
sardines in olive oil,
which you know I love olive oil.
So again, very reasonable
and very doable to eat a healthy diet.
It's not something I recommend,
but I found that a food
that allows me to bored eat
and still be quite healthy
and match my caloric intake is popcorn.
And this sea salt and
black pepper? Game changer.
Literally my favorite popcorn.
Every friend that I let
try this, they want it.
And it's actually hard to
find this flavor of Skinny Pop
so I'm glad they have it here
in the Amazon Fresh Store so.
- [Sam] Dang, dude!
- No, no, no, I need these.
Don't judge me.
Turkey. A lot of people treat
it as an underrated meat.
You're getting high protein content,
26 grams of protein per
serving, only 1% fat.
It's very lean.
Important reminder.
Cook your turkey to
165 degrees Fahrenheit.
That's crucial to make sure
that you're killing all those pathogens
that could potentially
be found in your turkey.
But otherwise, enjoy.
This is my morning fuel
before every boxing session.
I'm having Greek yogurt
with granola, with berries.
I like to get one
without the berries in it
and then add the berries myself.
That tends to have less preservatives.
Antioxidants in the berries
tend to last longer.
Therefore, being higher amounts
when I'm actually digesting them.
And I specifically go
for the Stonyfield brand.
There's other great brands out there,
but they have six live
active cultures in here.
All great species of good bacteria
that live naturally in your gut
that allow you to have
a healthy microbiome.
So keep those good bacteria fed.
So I got my food. I guess
it's just the scan and go.
Woo-wee!
It is time to celebrate.
Okay, that didn't work well.
All right, so we just gotta have
our 10 million celebration here.
We got Sam the man, Dan
the man, Bear the dog,
and we're about to enjoy the celebration.
Huge thank you for 10 million subs.
Click here to check out "The
Checkup with Doctor Mike."
It's a new podcast with
some amazing guests.
And don't forget to visit Amazon
Fresh locations nationwide.
Enjoy the affordable, fresh groceries
that they have for you.
And if you're a Prime
member, you can shop online.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
You guys have to say it too.
- Happy and healthy!
- [Mike] Huge thanks to Amazon Fresh
for sponsoring this video.